-Oh, my gosh.
-Wow.
-I'm wearing your suit.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
You're wearing my suit?
-I'm wearing your suit,
'cause I have a big
announcement, which is the show
I've been touring with,
which you've seen, called
"The Old Man & The Pool,"
and that Questlove
did the pre-show music for,
is going to Broadway.
-Yes! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a big announcement
right here.
-I showed up -- I showed up --
I showed up today,
and I'm wearing, like,
my corduroy shirt
that I was doing with the game
and everything,
and I was like,
I got to dress up.
It's Lincoln Center,
this is like, legit.
So I gotta look nice.
So if I can wear this for the
opening night, it'd be great.
-Yeah. You look -- you look
fantastic in my suit.
-Thank you so much.
-That really is my suit?
-Yeah, well, it belongs to NBC.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I guess it does.
-I'm not bringing this home.
-Wait, what theater?
Where are you -- this --
-It's gonna be the Vivian
Beaumont Theater
at Lincoln Center.
-Yeah.
-Broadway Lincoln Center,
and it's starting
October 28th through Christmas.
-So if you're in New York City
during the holidays...
-Perfect time.
-Dude, I'm so proud of you.
-It's happening for you.
-It's exciting.
-Yes!
-And you're so, honestly, like,
it's so much of
"The Tonight Show" DNA
because you've been
supportive of the show.
You came on my podcast
working it out,
you've been to two
of the live shows,
Questlove did the preshow music,
which is amazing.
I listened -- I was
just in Los Angeles.
I did the show for five weeks
at Marquee Performer,
and I would listen to
Questlove's preshow music
every night, and it's amazing.
It's got like "Sesame Street"
tracks in it.
-I --
-It's got like The Cure
and like all these, like,
great, amazing tracks.
-How'd you get Quest to --
to do that?
-I watched master class
about deejaying.
[ Laughter ]
True story.
I watched his master class
about deejaying,
and it's so good.
I highly recommend it.
-Yeah.
-And then I was like I want this
to be before my show,
like when people are coming in.
And so I tried to do it myself,
and I was like,
"This is much harder
than he makes it seem
in his master class."
So I called and I said,
like, would you be willing
to try this, and he did it
as a favor,
and it's like
I'm behind grateful.
It's just amazing.
-Mike, I remember walking
through this with you.
Like, yeah, I don't
if there's a show here,
but I think there is
and I'm going to grow it
and hopefully, you know, the
goal is to get it on Broadway.
-Yeah.
And I was like, "Alright,"
and I never mentioned it
to you ever again
'cause I don't want
to jinx anything.
-Yeah, and I appreciate that.
So, we mounted it
for the first time
with like the full set design
and everything in Los Angeles,
and it's been the most
gratifying performing experience
in my life, because it's about
life and death and mortality
and all these things that, like,
people don't want to talk about.
But the things that people say
when they come up to me
are so sweet.
Like, this guy was like,
"I brought my 12-year-old son,
and on the way home, like,
we talked about the afterlife,"
you know what I mean?
And like, I had this woman
come up and say, like,
"I lost my dad a few years ago,
and tonight I felt like I was
watching the show with my dad."
-Yeah. It's --
it's moving things.
-I mean, the theater's haunted,
so take it with a grain of salt.
-[ Laughs ] "The theatre's
haunted."
But there's so many lines
in there -- I just, I mean,
you probably want to delete my
phone number from your contacts,
'cause I was like, "Alright,
no I love this line.
Oh, no, and then
I love this line."
Then "this is my
favorite line."
I don't want to give anything
away, but there's --
there's so many great lines
in this show.
-Well, it's funny
'cause I loved it when you came,
because your laugh is so --
you're like such
a generous laugher.
And -- and as a comedian -- as a
comedian, you just crave that.
And then the funniest thing is,
when my friends would come,
typically like, the -- 'cause I
talk about having a lot of
pre-existing conditions.
I have a sleep walking disorder,
I had cancer when I was 20,
like, a lot of things,
and people come up to me
afterwards
and are like, "Are you okay?"
And --
[ Laughter ]
For real, and I'm like -- and
after a while I'm like,
"Am I?"
You know what I mean?
-No, you're fine.
-But I came back to New York
after the Los Angeles trip
and I was like, "I'm going
to go get a cystoscopy."
This is 'cause I had bladder
cancer when I was 20,
but it's funny because
I'm a hypochondriac,
and I think the funniest thing
that can happen
to a hypochondriac
is you get cancer.
You know what I mean?
'Cause you're like, "See?
I told you!"
-No, no --
-"Remember last week when
I thought I had Rickets?
I was probably right
about that, too!"
-Yeah, you're --
-There's gonna be
a lot of changes around here."
-"Rickets."
-Um, no, but I was --
I was lucky because
they took it --
when I was 20,
they took it out,
but I have to go for this thing
called a cystoscopy,
and so they take a -- a rod --
they, like,
take a camera and they
stick it through
your penis to look and --
[ Audience ohs ]
No, I know what you're thinking,
"Mike, a camera
can't fit through a penis."
Good news and bad news
on that front.
[ Laughter ]
The good news is it can,
and the bad news
is the same as the good news.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
Thank you, Quest.
But here's -- here's what
happened.
-"The bad news is the same
as the good news."
-But here's what happened --
I went for this cystoscopy --
this was last week, I went.
'Cause I got nervous.
I'm like, "Well, maybe
it's been too long."
And I went in, and, like,
I don't use drugs
recreationally, and so when
they give me drugs, it's wild.
Like, I'm like, "We should
do this all the time!"
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Like, it was -- and then --
-You got into it.
-Yeah, I got so into it,
and I was like, I said to
the anesthesiologist
before I went under,
I go, like "What is --
what is this?"
And he goes "It's propofol."
And I go, "Oh, isn't the one
that killed Michael Jackson?"
And he goes "And Joan Rivers."
And I was like --
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "This isn't, like,
a 'yes and' situation."
[ Laughter ]
"This isn't, like, a brainstorm
of who died doing
the thing you're about to do."
-No! Stop -- stop saying
those things.
Oh, my God.
-I wanted them to be, like,
"Yeah, but there were a lot
of other circumstances.
He had, like, an amusement park
in his yard,"
you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-But instead, but how --
-So then I did it, and then I
was all clear, no cancer.
-Good.
-Yeah, which was great.
Thanks, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, no, truly.
And then I came out,
and I was so high,
and I'm saying to my wife,
I'm just like,
"We should do this at home."
You know what I mean?
Like, the propofol.
And --
-[ Laughs ]
And we should get the amusement
park, I mean, why not?
-Yeah, why not?
-If you're gonna do one,
why not do the other?
And -- I was like --
-We do this at home.
-I was like, I became, like,
the guy at the music festival
who's just like,
"It's natural, bro,"
you know what I mean?
Like, "you can do it."
I was, like, I literally said --
I go, "It's lipids.
It's just made of lipids."
I don't even know
what lipids are, but I --
[ Laughter ]
I'd ask the anesthesiologist,
and he's like "It's lipids."
And I said to my wife,
I go, "It's lipids.
Don't worry about it.
We can do this."
[ Laughter ]
And like, "It can't kill you."
And the anesthesiologist goes,
"Yeah, it can."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I got so high,
and I think I'm still high.
I put on your suit. I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-And you look fantastic.
-How does it look?
-Look at Mike Birbiglia.
He looks great.
You look fantastic.
That's what a man
on a Broadway does.
Mike Birbiglia, everybody.
Mike returns to Broadway
with his new show
"The Old Man & The Pool"
starting October 28th.